hey this is matt from NMR today we're
going to talk with brian m cox he's a
Grammy award-winning producer he's
launching a new website called blaze
track which is going to be accepting
artists music submissions he's going to
be giving them back video feedback it's
a kind of a cool idea hey Brian how's it
going I'm good how are you very good so
for anyone not familiar what is blaze
track all about well blades track
basically is it as a service where you
know up and coming producers song
writers artists executives can come and
basically connect with you know
professionals in the business basically
you pay a fee and you get a direct
response in the direct interaction with
the professional and in some cases you
might even get put on and that's where
the whole purpose of it the whole
purpose is for you to connect to get put
on me to get a job if you're trying to
get a song heard if you're trying to get
your production earth I know a few
people that's literally you know been
discovered off of this thing so it's
really really a positive movement in
this and it's you know if it works it
absolutely works right absolutely you
know you're primarily known for R&B
songs and producing being an R&B
producer are you accepting songs that
are you know maybe punk rock rap
anything like that absolutely it's me
out some people out of time no good
songs good song where there is rock
country R&B no mission no copyright is
the copyright no matter how you
chocolate right absolutely you know um
so what does blade track kind of offered
that working with a producer actually in
person would an offer when I was coming
up I there was no way I could get the
Teddy Riley there was no way I could get
to you know in my favorite producers
when I was coming up that was like so
that a faint fantasy you know obsession
um I think that what blaze track does it
takes what Twitter and was social
networking and social media does it
takes it to the next level because now
what happens is you can only get direct
advice from me you know i might say hey
I want to work with you like you heard I
or some that was incredible and
to do with it I'm out of work with you
let's work out a deal I think that's the
best thing my place track and then it
okay this community of people and of
artists then grow together you know I
mean and you get direct mentorship from
The Ballad mean I think that's prices
right absolutely how do you handle
someone sends you a track or sends you
something and it's like Rebecca Black
Friday style like it's not good it's as
real bad I mean how do you come at that
and still be nice but also be okay this
is pretty bad people will be more
offended you you know you take them out
there locks alone and so that is good
now online it's not i sees always the
best recipe you know it hurts now but
you learn from it I know when I came
into the music business and I was
hustling my songs around the city of
Atlanta you know I got hit with a with
some real honesty you know me and it
hurt but also inspired me and motivated
me to get better I had mad respect for
the people i was getting opinions from
so it motivated me I didn't look at it
like all were they ain't know me you
know people like to always say that
somebody ain't know if it's a bad
something I want you to keep shuffling
that bad song around making yourself
look bad and if I say it's good and it's
bad and maybe looks bad yo so I don't
have a problem you know being honest I'm
not gonna be mmm no not me guy but I'm
gonna be honest opinion you know you
were talking about coming up as a young
producer and social media didn't really
exist when you were around at that time
how would have had in social media in
the same vein that Justin Bieber came up
on YouTube have changed your process as
an artist I think that if I had
something if I was coming up now I
probably be so all over the place
because I believe that I have an outlet
like not in the 90s it wasn't an outlet
you know I'm saying it wasn't really no
no I grew up in Houston Texas so in the
90s in Houston Texas you know to get to
music heard it was like impossible now I
can talk to a seventeen-year-old Houston
Texas or a ton of them and they can get
their music you know they don't have to
worry about Hanukkah talent I'm gonna
get to New York you know I mean when I
was coming up it was like yo I gotta get
to New York I gotta get down lane I got
la and how am I gonna do that and now
with the onset of Technology and you
know the laptops and August whole nine
people making music on laptops you know
me now I'm talking in a laptop the same
laptop that I actually write songs on
and I could mix my songs on a laptop you
could really make records do your
artwork do your video do the interview
with PR jobs and edit the video I mean
you can do everything with just one
thing right now we're back on a day it
took so much to me and so many things
have to pass on to get done so I'm like
if I had this oh I'd probably be you
know I probably be a billionaire is
because they don't mean just the hustle
that I have along with what technology
brings about a not here you know damn
but it's just you know it all starts
with your personal your desire and your
um your needle not to make it absolutely
you know there's definitely argument
that can be made that you know those
traditional methods that you had to go
through it really kind of separated
people who really wanted it versus
people who were kind of maybe doing as a
hobby because there was so much hustle
in it you had to physically meet with
people now there's not there's still a
different kind of hustle but it's still
easier for people to get into it and for
you know you can just post on YouTube
free of charge whatever and anyone can
see it do you feel like that's kind of
making the industry harder to penetrate
and harder to break into at this point
it's harder and it's easier at the same
time which is amazing to me somebody
could be posting something for a year
posting something on YouTube posting
their songs for a year and not get one
look you know one thing could trigger
something one of those videos and then
it blows up you take the whole baauer
harlem shake phenomenon you know i mean
if i was been around for how long doing
dubstep and no man so this is random he
randomly named this track harlem shake
randomly your college students got a
hold of it and it turns into this
phenomenon on youtube and 19 kids no
more breaking on billboard he's making
apps let me just within like past month
then have really been a month yet your
head and he's like a phenomena he's
credible he's awesome right Rebecca
Black is terrible rightly so for every
that that's where I go one in ism
on one hand it isn't because it's like
anything to kind of get through the door
about the fault if you are really
talented and got some hustle you'll keep
going lucky justin bieber keep kids he's
got one he became a phenomenon names and
Rebecca Black not so much so you can
decipher for what's good and what's not
you know if something hits and it's good
that person is going to keep going if
something is it is just like a you know
antoine dodson you know then it's not as
you leave it in others i'm just calling
names out because i'm just thinking of
people that i don't see anymore you know
you've worked with artists like mary j
blige Usher and Mariah Carey why are you
looking for new talent with blaze track
that's a creative mind you have to
evolve can't stay stuck in the same
place every year is this new writers
this new producers his new creative
minds that breakthrough [ __ ] every day
not every day I still haven't done my
best work yet and a lot of that has to
do with surrounding myself around young
vibrant talented inspiring people and
that's what this whole thing is about
right absolutely so I gotta ask the
producer question standard producer
question you know which artists have you
worked with that has been your favorite
to work with I mariah's always smooth
sailing she always calls no she's she's
so too might consider a friend because
she always calls every album she calls
she's about who's hot too but she's not
really buy that she don't really be like
oh well such and such as hot now I'm
gonna go get him and not call the people
that yeah you know that I usually work
with it she was one of the most loyal
people in the business her Monica who
was one of my best friends Monica's my
son's godmother I love a model uh she's
incredible Mary wasn't pudding was
incredible to work with everybody worked
with it's been great but you know Monica
Mariah have a special placement awesome
awesome thanks very thanks for answering
that you're my last question is what are
you hoping to see what are you expecting
to see from your submissions well for me
the in goal for the whole search is to
find a new producer song or songwriter
that that's inspiring now it to me but I
can inspire the world I mean I have a
new company that a star
a sniff [ __ ] music group and we can
read a partner to put a label I can't we
talk too much about it but of course
this songwriter producer will be heavily
involved in that and what they actually
do with that so I'm really in process of
building this company I want to build a
really good artist roster but I also
want to do a little bit of really
incredible creative roster from art from
up from a producer and songwriter
perspective absolutely well I appreciate
it really appreciate you taking the time
to talk to me matter really very very
thank you very much no doubt man thank
you man hey thank you checking our
interview with brian michael cox for
more interviews like this check out
youtube.com slash new meteor rock stars
especially check out our interview with
nate bennett of the okay Nate channel
he's part of my damn channel network
it's very cool and I was always please
remember to subscribe thanks a lot